we're going to begin this hour with the
third part of our series that we call
Facing fertility this morning we are
focusing on menopause that's the end of
fertility for women and now more than
ever women including big names like
Michelle Obama Naomi Watts and others
they're coming forward to say we got to
talk about this most women start
menopause around the ages of say 51 52 5
of women experience early menopause that
means between the ages of 40 and 45 and
one percent experience it even before
the age of 40. so talking about
menopause we know this isn't always
comfortable but it's so very very
important that's why Drew Barrymore and
I said yes when Nikki batis asked us
let's sit down and have a conversation
we started that conversation with
perimenopause that's when many women
start to notice changes as the body
starts transitioning toward the inward
menopause
was there an aha moment where you
thought I'm in perimenopause I realized
that I was in perimenopause when I
started having my period every two weeks
um and then that wasn't it a heavy flow
that's a sign yes like a teenager well
one doctor also just told me like this
could last you know on the worst case
scenario 10 10 years and I was like I
will never make it 10 years like this
well I did well
I did another thing
it can last 10 years I mean the
perimenopause doesn't last 10 years but
I still have you know they say by the
time you're 50 definitely there's
there's something going on I'm just glad
we're even having this conversation
Nikki because I didn't even know the
phrase perimenopause same I had never
even heard I'd heard of menopause but
I'd never even heard the phrase
perimenopause until I went to the doctor
because you know not to get too graphic
but when it first happens for a lot of
people it looked like a crime scene
since you've been through the whole
process but I still I don't think I'm
done because I still have hot flashes
you still do I still do not as much as I
used to not as much as I used to a
couple couple times during covet I'm
like is this covert or is this menopause
what does a hot flash feel like because
that I'm not getting yet feels like it
starts with it feels like you're burning
inside and then like acid reflux no it
just feels hot okay just for me it was
just a physical heat and then you can
sometimes have dripping drenching sweats
it just can happen at the most
inopportune times I've been on the red
carpet where photographers say kale are
you okay I go it's just a hot flash and
they go oh sorry sorry it's like people
when you say I'm having hot oh sorry
sorry like they've said something very
bad about you but that's why I think
it's good we're saying yes
dry vagina it's all part of it most
people just hear menopause and think
it's hot flashes that's all it is but
it's so much more why has hot flashes
been marketed so well where people go oh
sure but if you say perimenopause I'm in
menopause you know I'm experiencing this
most of it seems very unfamiliar and
confusing not just to men but but women
did either of you seek any treatment go
talk to a doctor I did talk to a doctor
but I didn't take any hormones you know
I know friends that have creams or they
take
medication and I I just I've just sort
of weathered through it when I realized
you really don't have to do that I was
offered hormone therapy and I said no
why because I really didn't feel like
the Doctor Who was suggesting it
understood where I was at and it seemed
preemptive and I'm like until I get so
desperate and this is also obvious I
don't want to take something
preemptively at some point there might
be a treatment that's right for you so
don't do it too fast but don't be a hero
unnecessarily if you don't need to be
don't be a hero the the reason why I
think this is hard is because when you
think of menopause you think of old yeah
you think of old her life is over she's
done put her out to pasture yes and what
we know is that's just not true that if
there's any message we could get across
I think that would be the one that would
be the most helpful how do we change the
conversation about menopause to be this
humorous you keep talking because it is
it is kind of funny the crime scene
everything is kind of funny I think the
more women also you know in their 40s
50s and 60s are looking so attractive
feeling so vibrant living their best
lives the way menopause has been branded
is you're old you're done that's not it
yeah you're old you're done your vagina
is dry yeah you have no value in society
anymore you're not attractive they're
not attractive it's like cobwebs down
there yeah I mean you're not
that's not true also also the other
thing Nikki is you don't have to have
drastic symptoms not everybody has these
kind of symptoms I know some women who
they've been through it and they've just
sort of sailed to it have had very
minimal things it wasn't disruptive to
their life that was not my experience
but my mother also had very bad symptoms
but she never talked about listen I
remember being on vacation with my mom
and she had white pants and her period
came on she was in menopause it had to
be perimenopause and this Blood started
gushing I said what is happening she
goes oh nothing nothing I'm fine I'm
fine I'm fine no conversation about it
why is that why has that been the way
for so long yes even our own mom yes
because they were embarrassed and it was
in a generational thing it was
generational it was improper and
indelicate to talk about you're not
raising Frankie and Olive that way I'm
sure yeah
I was just gonna say I have to tell the
guy Bo's mom I was just gonna say that I
think you have to have a conversation
with your boys as well but I do think
kids boys and girls should be well
informed I don't want little boys going
ew I don't want that because it is
something that we go through and it's
just you know male and female there are
differences and those differences are
okay if you were to use one word One
phrase to describe how we should think
about menopause what would it be
one word
um reality
mine's natural Ah that's good I think
ours are really as usual hand in hand
that's good yeah reality
and OB GYN who specializes in menopause
told me that hormone replacement therapy
can be safe and effective if it's done
at the right age for the right amount of
time what that time frame is can vary
from Woman to Woman another doctor told
us that women who reach menopause before
45 especially Before 40 should strongly
consider hormone replacement therapy
yeah all the doctors will tell you that
it is safe we did something with Dr
Sharon Malone at Oprah daily she says we
need to stop normalize she's also a
doctor who specializes that in this stop
normalizing suffering around this you
know it seems such a taboo and
uncomfortable thing but I think Michelle
Obama says it but she says you know when
you reach menopause be glad that you've
reached it it just shows you're at
another stage of life she says there's
no shame in my menopause game and I
think we have to figure out a better way
to reframe the conversation so it
doesn't make people uncomfortable
including men I think including little
boys
throughout this conversation that you
were having I think Tony and I were we
kept asking questions I'm stunned at my
own ignorance yeah when it comes to this
particular subject I'm actually stunned
and I consider myself somebody who kind
of knows a lot of things about a lot of
things and I don't know anything as much
as I should about this and I have a
little girl yes understanding is
understanding is being able to make us
feel more comfortable and I think for me
I always worried will I be less
desirable will I be less sexy when I hit
menopause but okay you're living proof
that no and the answer is no the answer
really is no I mean there's just so much
stuff that happens to a woman's body you
guys are so lucky in that in that
respect there's so we have so many
moving parts and so much stuff that
happens I don't feel you guys have half
the stuff have to go through half the
stuff we do not a competition
Gail I want to thank you and Drew for
your transparency and having this
conversations so many others yeah I also
want to thank our facing fertility
series producers Hillary cook and Rachel
Bailey and Chris Hassan they've been
wonderful and a personal thanks to my
fertility doctor Dr Eric Foreman at
Columbia University Fertility Center
yes I'm really proud of you and our show
for doing this me too but Nikki guided
us through it you know because Drew and
I could both be long talkers I think he
has a tendency let's get back on track
girls this is what we're talking about I
learned so much thank you all done well
done natural and reality those are the
two words all right thank you very much